destrucción endonietsky dejan los
intensos bombardeos rusos también en la
universidad de economía y comercio
cayeron bombas el presidente ucraniano
Vladimir zelenzi habló de las
dificultades en el frente sobre todo en
el don vast la situación en la línea del
frente sigue siendo muy difícil en las
zonas clave del Don vastmut soledad
marinca cremimina los ocupantes han
destruido prácticamente más común en
tanto la embajadora de Reino Unido ante
la ONU denunció que Rusia intenta
comprar a Irán cientos de misiles
balísticos
desde agosto Teherán a transferido
cientos de vehículos a Moscú
infringiendo el derecho internacional
Rusia ha utilizado esos drones iraníes
para matar a civiles y atacar
ilegalmente infraestructuras civiles
por su parte el presidente ruso Vladimir
Putin afirmó que es probable que su país
tenga que llegar a acuerdos en relación
con Ucrania en el futuro a pesar de que
acusó Alemania y Francia de darle armas
a kiev y así incumplir los acuerdos de
Minsk de 2014 y 2015 cuando mediaron en
el alto el fuego entre Ucrania y los
separatistas Pro rusos de crimea todo lo
que se está diciendo Ahora solo
demuestra que lo que hicimos estuvo bien
en relación con el inicio de la
operación militar especial por qué
Porque resulta que nadie quiere cumplir
todos estos acuerdos de mings Putin se
mostró Decepcionado de los comentarios
de La canciller alemana Angela Merkel en
los que decía que estos acuerdos fueron
un intento de dar tiempo a Ucrania para
construir sus defensas